we've talked about using intents within
sunshine to start activities and send
data between arts but what if you want
to broadcast a message too many apps for
example the system will broadcast a
message saying that the device is
charging or that it's just finished
rebooting to do that ourselves we use
the sent broadcast method to broadcast
an intent and those broadcasts are
received by broadcast receivers
typically referred to as simply
receivers using intent filters like the
ones we saw earlier they indicate which
broadcasts they're interested in so if
you return to our envelope metaphor from
earlier in the case of a broadcast
intent your envelope is basically
addressed to any broadcast receiver
that's interested in knowing that this
event has happened and it does that
using an intent filter so intents which
are broadcast are transmitted to every
app with a broadcast receiver that has
an intent filter telling the system your
ideas are intriguing to me and I wish to
subscribe to your newsletter